I'm living for the seventh heaven
reunion that is happening on this red
carpet also we've got a Lance Bass here
too
friends from the 90s who are here
tonight there's a lot of Y2K happening
right now speaking of had to bring it
out 2001 Jessica Biel with the crib what
is that they look uncomfortable I'm like
this isn't right it's not right
what would 2001 Jessica Biel say if she
knew later down the road she would marry
a Y2K icon Justin Timberlake
literally be like you're full of it
whatever I have no idea what you're
talking about good luck you're in a bad
dream
we had so much fun on the Cruel Summer
red carpet and at the after party we
caught Jess rocking out to one of her
hubby's hits
[Music]
the executive producer is celebrating
season two of her hit freeform series
which returns Monday with a whole new
cast a love triangle and murder mystery
all set in Y2K people are gonna start
asking questions
we have to get our story straight but on
the LA carpet it was all about the
seventh heaven reunion she's my bestie
she's my ride or die were you surprised
at how much the internet loved your Tick
Tock about the wild story lines on
Seventh Heaven Was an alcoholic my
sister was hooked on Natural Energy
boosters and my brother had a baggy
pants face I mean it's it's very funny
because the reality is I I don't
remember a lot I think the fans remember
more than I do wow
excuse me what do you remember about
that Cameo literally two decades ago
well it was my first acting job ever so
I didn't know what the hell I was doing
what would 2002 Lance pass say if he
knew years later his bandmate would then
be marrying the star of the show
well I was hoping because uh you know I
loved Jesse from that show so I was very
happy that they found each other later
we are too Lance